[MUSIC PLAYING]
SOROUSH RADPOUR: Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Soroush and
let's get it started.
I'm going to focus on
Kubeflow Pipelines.
It is our product for helping
developers go from prototyping
to a real production system.
So the agenda for
today is I'm going
to give you an overview
of our motivation
and our approach for how we
build Kubeflow Pipelines,
and then I'm going
to give you some
of the examples of the
problems that inspired Kubeflow
Pipelines and what we heard from
the customers and their needs,
and last, I will show
you some of the features
that Kubeflow
Pipelines has currently
and how you can use it.
So let's go through
the motivation first.
So if you have worked on machine
learning deployments before,
you know that building
and deploying ML models
is hard and costly.
In order to go end-to-end from
grabbing the data to having
the model serving and so on,
there is much more than just
building the model.
So the problems that we
see today in AI are--
at least three of them that
we are trying to tackle
is deployment, where there
are different solutions
for different frameworks.
And each cloud
provider might want
you to use their solution
for a specific AI problem,
and then when you
want to go to on-prem
or switch between clouds,
they usually break
or they're not even supported.
So the next one
is finding talent
and really using the
talent's time effectively.
ML expertise is
not easy to come by
and you want to really
use their ML expert time
as efficiently as possible.
And lastly, the ecosystem is--
the problem with
the ecosystem is
that it is difficult to find
and reuse what is out there.
If you know that a new model
came out for image processing,
for example, and you
want to grab that model
and use it in your
production system,
finding it and using it
in your production system
takes a lot of effort.
So our solution
to these problems,
it is Kubeflow, reusable
pipelines, and AI Hub.
So I'm going to go
through these one by one.
So what is Kubeflow?
It is built on top of
Kubernetes to let you train
your machine learning models.
It has support for PyTorch,
TensorFlow, XGBoost,
and a lot of other
popular frameworks.
It also takes care
of serving and so on,
so it is more end-to-end.
It has support for GPU
and multi-node training
so it can scale up or down
depending on your problem.
And you can run it on any
Kubernetes deployment,
so if you have your own
cluster at your company,
you don't want to
use GCP, great--
if you have a
Kubernetes deployment,
you can install
Kubeflow on top of it--
but there is also GCP support.
Next is reusable pipelines.
The goal is basically enabling
an engineer or a machine
learning expert
to not waste time
on rebuilding and reinventing
everything from scratch
but picking the pieces
that were built before
and really just reusing and
building what they care about.
So discoverability of,
like, are reusable pipelines
is the problem, and AI
Hub tries to tackle that.
AI Hub is a product
that Google has
built that you can search
for the type of problem
you're trying to solve and
find solutions that are already
built for that type of problem.
And very easily build your
pipeline around those.
So you can stitch them together
and build your pipeline there.
It is really fast
and easy to use.
There is a one-click
installation
for Kubeflow on GCP.
So if you found
something that you
want to use from the AI Hub,
you can easily deploy it
on your GCP account, basically.
There is also
enterprise-level sharing.
So what I mean is that,
within your company,
if you have built
something that is
interesting to other teams,
other employees of the company,
you can share that solution
with the rest of the company.
And also if you want
to share it publicly,
you can also say I want to share
this publicly so everyone can
use it.
So next I'm going to talk
about the type of problems that
inspired Kubeflow Pipelines.
Let's say you have your problem
that you are trying to solve.
You figure out where
you can gather the data
types that you care about
for this type of problem.
You create your CSV file,
you do your pre-processing
of that file and have your
Python for pre-processing,
and then you have
another Python file
for like training the model and
it will produce a model file.
And you are trying
to figure out,
how do you go from
that model file
to something you can
have in the production?
And soon you will
see there is more
to that, like once I
go beyond the ML model,
you might want to look at
how the model quality changes
over time.
If you just put the model
out, is the model still
as performant as it was
when you first deploy it?
So there is monitoring.
And then you think about,
how can I continuously deploy
this model?
So with the first year
that it is coming in,
I want to create a new
model, push that new model
to the production.
How do I monitor new
versions of the model?
How do I scale the
serving of the model
so that, like, if there
is new traffic coming in,
I can easily respond to that.
When the new data
is coming in, you
want to verify the
new data so that like,
if there is a regression
somewhere in the pipeline that
produces that input data, you
want to be able to catch that.
So as you were
looking through it,
it can grow to really
a hard problem.
So this is a tweet
that talks about
like, she developed
the model in three
weeks but going to a production
system took almost a year.
So what we hear from customers
from different companies
is that using these tools
for workflow management
for pipeline management that are
not built for machine learning,
they have trouble
applying it to machine
learning because
there are machine
learning specific things.
For example, you care about
metrics in machine learning.
For each model, that
can be different.
You care about experimenting
with different hyperparameters
and different model
versions are different
and there are things that
are very specific to machine
learning that you can't just use
any pipeline management system.
And if you don't have any
pipeline management system,
then your models might
be working today,
but as the data changes and
the user behavior changes,
the models become stale
and updating the model
might take many, many steps.
You might have to run few
jobs manually to grab the data
and train the model and test
to make sure it is actually
performing as you expect and
then push it to production.
And if you want to do it every
week, it is a lot of overhead.
And lastly, experimentation
of different hyperparameters
is difficult. There is
no good way of tracking
what was the hyperparameter
that was used for this model.
So if in the future, like
a month from the time
that the model was
trained, you want
to look back and see how was
this model trained, tracking
that and being able to
reproduce the same model
or change your
model is difficult.
And these are the
kind of problems
that the customers had.
So that is why we built
Kubeflow Pipelines.
So next, I'll give
you an overview
of the Kubeflow Pipelines.
The features it has.
The first piece of it is
orchestrating your system.
Basically, in your pipeline, you
will have different components
that are responsible
for peer processing
here or transforming,
training, and so on.
And Kubeflow Pipeline is
responsible for making sure
that the dependencies
are met and it
will execute the containers
in the right order
and takes care of
distribution of them.
You can also take a
look at the trainer job
and look at the metrics
that it provides.
So if you click on
the trainer, you
can see the ROC
curve in this case
that the trainer was providing.
If it was a TensorFlow job,
it will have a TensorBoard
if you have used
TensorFlow before.
But if it is like
XGBoost model, it
will have its own
visualizations of its metrics.
You can also look at the
logs during training.
If there was any
errors or something,
you can take a look here.
And the configuration that
was used for the trainer.
So as I said, the Pipeline
is basically a set of tasks--
ML tasks-- and we use
containers to encapsulate
all it needs to run.
Make the code portable
and repeatable.
A task can be run on a single
machine or a distributed
fashion, and Kubeflow
will take care of that.
And there is a
Python SDK that lets
you specify the steps that
your pipeline needs to run
and the dependencies
between the different steps.
And it provides a
way for you to say
what are the parameters
to these pipelines.
An example of a
parameter to a pipeline
can be like hyperparameters
for learning rates
or for the optimizer to use
or it can be the input files
that you want to process or what
is the column in your CSV file
that has the labeling.
So it will be easier to
reuse if you parameterize it.
Here is an example
of a Jupyter notebook
that you have input
your pipeline here.
There is peer processing,
training and analysis,
and prediction and deploy steps.
And it is just as easy as
a few lines of Python code
to build a pipeline and run
it on the Kubeflow cluster.
Next is how you
reliably experiment
and you can rapidly change
and develop your model.
So the cycle for
experimentation is basically
that you pick some
hyperparameters
that you want to try.
Let's say I want to try 100
trees, 200 trees, and so on.
And you submit a bunch of runs.
You wait for the results.
You get some outputs
out of those results
and now you want to look
at which one of these runs
had the best results and
maybe clone the best one,
modify it, and run it again
with different configuration,
maybe slightly
differently, and experiment
and improve your model.
So this is the UI for
tracking your models.
You can see that
all the runs are
grouped by their experiments.
So if you're experimenting
with like an image model,
and like here, there's
a TFMA experiment,
XGBoost train experiment.
And they can have
multiple runs, and these
are previous runs that finished
and there is a currently
running job here.
And you can easily
clone an existing run.
So you open one of the runs,
you see that it has a good ROC,
you can click on the Clone here
or look at the configuration
and create a copy of it.
And when you create
a copy of it,
it will fill out the
parameters that you provided,
but you can update
the parameters.
So you will say here, instead
of like number of trees, 200,
you want 300 trees this time.
And it is just as easy
to iterate on your model.
So comparing between
runs is very easy.
It will give you--
basically for an experiment,
you will see a list of metrics
and you can compare different
runs and how they performed.
And if you want to dig
deeper into each of these,
you can select, let's
say, like three of them
and click on Compare Runs.
And that way, you'll get
a deep dive on those three
how they compare
against each other.
Yeah.
You get the metrics,
AUC, and so on.
The last piece of the puzzle was
sharing and reusing components.
So as we said, we
wanted to reuse
and compose instead of
reimplementing and reinventing
everything.
So in this example
that we saw previously,
these steps are actually
coming from AI Hub.
So once you've found
the right component that
does what you care about,
calling it in your pipeline
is as easy as just calling the
function in your Python code.
And we find the
containers that needs
to run as part of
this AI Hub component
and we'll add it to your
pipeline, basically.
Yeah, that's all there is.
Yeah.
Any questions now?
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: What is
the backend for this?
[INAUDIBLE]
SOROUSH RADPOUR: There
is a combination of--
AUDIENCE: Can you
repeat the question?
SOROUSH RADPOUR: Oh, right.
So the question was,
what is the backend
that this is implemented in?
It is a combination of--
so Kubernetes itself
and on top of it.
So there is some Go and Python.
And obviously, like the
components that you call,
it can be any language.
And also, they can call
other cloud services,
so within your
code, you can have
a component that uses DataProc
or DataFlow for distributed
data processing.
Or like, it can use
BigQuery and all that.
AUDIENCE: Hadoop as well?
SOROUSH RADPOUR: Yeah.
So like you don't have to
use Python or Go or anything.
As long as you have your
code in a container,
you can run it as
part of this pipeline.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the talk.
So the [INAUDIBLE] for
dividing the pipeline.
SOROUSH RADPOUR:
OK, OK, over there.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When does building
images come into this?
So I see you were talking
about making everything
have a hyperparameter.
SOROUSH RADPOUR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Like how does it work?
[INAUDIBLE] on the code
and how [INAUDIBLE]
SOROUSH RADPOUR: So
there is some code
that basically takes care of
containerizing your notebook.
So if your model is
in your notebook,
it will look at your
state of whatever you
have loaded in your Python
and takes a snapshot of that
and puts it in a container
so it can run it remotely
on a distributed system.
AUDIENCE: It's
fair to say, then,
this is a way to version
all the different models
and versioning also
the input data sets?
SOROUSH RADPOUR: Yeah.
Basically, there is a
versioning for models.
Is that the question?
Yeah.
And like, you can go back
to a version of the model
and see how was it
produced and what
was the configuration
for that version.
AUDIENCE: So following
off of that, is it then
possible to say, sweep
through some of the parameters
and look at the effect
of how the model behaved?
SOROUSH RADPOUR: Sorry,
I didn't hear you.
AUDIENCE: Can you sweep
through different parameters?
You've showed
[INAUDIBLE] where you
can compare different models.
SOROUSH RADPOUR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And if I wanted
to sweep through a parameter
and see--
SOROUSH RADPOUR: OK, so
hyperparameter tuning.
Is that the question?
So the question
is, is there a way
to basically try variations
of different parameters
and automatically find the
best parameter settings, right?
Is that?
AUDIENCE: The
automatic [INAUDIBLE]..
SOROUSH RADPOUR: Yeah.
So there is like
a Katib library,
I believe, for hyperparameter
tuning in Kubeflow.
I haven't used it personally
but it provides a way to say,
like, these are my
hyperparameters.
This is the space that
you are searching for.
And it will do the automatic
search for parameters,
basically.
It will not do like a linear
sweep of the parameter
but it will try
different experiments
and different
hyperparameter values
and pick the best
one, basically.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was more concerned
to, like, performance.
Say, for example, I wanted
to find the minimum set of--
like input set that
I can train on.
Right?
So I can-- like, if there
was multiple trainings
and I could sweep
across that and then see
what my performance is.
SOROUSH RADPOUR: So--
AUDIENCE: Is that something
I can't really do [INAUDIBLE]
SOROUSH RADPOUR:
The question is--
let me see if I can
understand the question right.
You have different sets of input
and you want to try them all
and see which set of inputs
provide the best model
or minimum set of the--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SOROUSH RADPOUR: So you can
treat that as a hyperparameter
to the model.
So like you provide all
the sets to the model
and then the hyperparameter
that says how many of these use
during training, for example.
And it can be one,
two, three, four, five,
if you have five data sets, and
see which one provides the best
model.
Or see all of them and see
which one is acceptable quality
for you, for example.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SOROUSH RADPOUR: OK.
AUDIENCE: I'll
bring you the mic.
One second.
AUDIENCE: So I
couldn't understand
is how I should
[INAUDIBLE] will be
embedded into this
[INAUDIBLE],, just directly if I
get it right.
So you show these boxes for
each spaces of my pipeline
and I can click on
[INAUDIBLE] write calls
like using one of the
supported libraries and it
be brought into Docker container
and executed from the existing
pipeline, or like?
SOROUSH RADPOUR: So let
me go back a little bit.
These are components.
So a component is when you have
already developed your Python
code and you have
built a container
and you expose it as a
component to a pipeline.
And so there is support
for pre-containerized code,
so like if you have built your
Docker containers somewhere
else, you can use
it in pipelines.
If you have your Python code
somewhere else in this Jupyter
notebook, you can say, I
create a container from that
and then I create a component
that calls that container.
And that also works.
So when you look
at this pipeline,
there is no way to
edit this right now--
like you can edit it at this
stage because it is running.
This is showing like
a result of a run.
Editing happens before
you create a pipeline.
So you write your
pipeline across a bunch
of containers and so
on, and when you run it,
you will get that
nice graph, basically.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So container needs to
be built in advance
by me or [INAUDIBLE].
So how are you manage input and
output of the different phases?
SOROUSH RADPOUR:
So the API supports
some pre-processing--
is a stage here
and peer processing
has that output.
So it can provide a single
output or a list of outputs.
I don't know if it is visible.
But basically a component
can have a list of outputs,
and it can be used
in the future steps
of other steps in the pipeline.
So peer processing takes some
input and produces some output,
and training takes the output
from peer processing and so on.
AUDIENCE: Let's say I have
[INAUDIBLE] So let's say I have
[INAUDIBLE]
SOROUSH RADPOUR: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
So what I'm
placing somewhere on [INAUDIBLE]
input in [INAUDIBLE]??
SOROUSH RADPOUR: Yeah.
So you're passing-- here you
can see example of Google Cloud
Storage path as one of the
inputs and the output of the--
each component will
create a temp directory
on cloud and yeah.
AUDIENCE: What about [INAUDIBLE]
SOROUSH RADPOUR: So the Kubeflow
will have different deployment
environments, and
each environment
can say this is how
you create a job
and how to create that
temporary and so on.
So even on prem, you
don't have to use GS.
You can use anything.
AUDIENCE: I'm pretty
new to this [INAUDIBLE]..
I was going to ask where is the
containment field [INAUDIBLE]
SOROUSH RADPOUR: So in here, we
don't have any container here.
This is just using some
components that are predefined,
and these components, if you
look at the definition of them,
some of them are
coming from AI hub.
But the ones that are
not coming from AI hub
are defined in the same--
I don't know if I have any
example of that in the slides,
so let me quickly go back
and see if there is--
but basically you will say
this is the container name--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SOROUSH RADPOUR:
How do you specify?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SOROUSH RADPOUR: This is
open source by the way.
You can go through the examples.
There are some samples
for different [INAUDIBLE]
TensorFlow and so on.
And I encourage everyone to take
a look at the Jupyter notebooks
there.
In the notebooks,
they're using containers,
so you'll see some
example of that.
AUDIENCE: So one question
I had is [INAUDIBLE]
how do you transition
from [INAUDIBLE]??
SOROUSH RADPOUR: So there are--
for serving, there
are components
that are in charge
of serving, and they
are more or less specific.
So they have developed serving
a stack for XGBoost model
and TensorFlow model.
And I believe PyTorch is coming.
I don't know
exactly where it is.
But basically there are reusable
components for serving as well.
And you can say this is
deploy for TensorFlow,
so it will assume that the
input is TensorFlow model.
But there is a deploys
for XGBoost and so on.
So you can say deploy
this model and--
is that answering the question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SOROUSH RADPOUR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: When you
say [INAUDIBLE]
by default [INAUDIBLE]
something like that?
SOROUSH RADPOUR: So
the difference here
is that there is no
internal format here.
There are components that
provide XGBoost models,
and there are components
that serve XGBoost models.
So you can basically
build your pipeline
stitching these together.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
If I want to automate
[INAUDIBLE] is there a way
I can run validation
tests [INAUDIBLE]??
SOROUSH RADPOUR: So there is
a validation of the models,
for example.
You can say if the
model quality is not
as good as yesterday or
compared to yesterday,
the model quality is
dropping by this much.
Don't push a production.
Regression-- unit tests
are not supported,
but some continuous automated
pushing and validation
of the model is supported.
AUDIENCE: Are you in
production, and do you
have a production road map?
SOROUSH RADPOUR: So the
question is are we in production
and do we have a
production roadmap.
So currently it is an open
source project built mostly
by Google, but
there are partners
that are putting components
in the AI hub and so on.
So you can use it on prem or
on Google Cloud or anywhere
you have queries.
But we are planning to do
a hosted service for this
as well.
It will be just the managed
service but same feature.
Go ahead.
You had a question?
AUDIENCE: Databricks
has something similar
called MLflow.
Have you compared
this to their project
and what the differences are?
SOROUSH RADPOUR: I have not.
Is it-- I guess--
is it supposed to be
entwined and so on?
AUDIENCE: And it helps
you track your runs
and your hybrid parameters.
It's not in one dot 0 yet.
It think it's in point nine.
SOROUSH RADPOUR: This
is also not in one.
We just started.
So Kubeflow is a bit older,
but Kubeflow pipelines
is the next iteration on that.
And it focuses on reusable
pipelines and AI hub and so on.
So that is relatively less
than a year I would say.
AUDIENCE: I'm thinking
[INAUDIBLE] And so
that's more of our [INAUDIBLE].
It's [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: It's not
for deployment.
It's for tracking.
AUDIENCE: It's for tracking,
making sure that you have
[INAUDIBLE].
SOROUSH RADPOUR: Did
you have a question?
Sorry.
Never mind.
I thought you'd have a question.
All right.
I think that's it.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]